now this is how you turn 13. adam
sandler went all out for his daughter
sonny's bot mitzvah and so did the stars
yeah adam's famous friends came out to
celebrate sonny's special day one of
sunny's friends captured all the famous
faces at the birthday bash on tiktok
there's adam's grown-ups 2 co-star
taylor lautner and his huby halloween
cast mate peyton list both posing with a
candy plush sonny's friend seemingly
used as bait to capture the actors in
action i understand you've been friends
for quite some time yeah we've been
friends for i would say
21 years adam's frequent collaborators
jennifer aniston and david spade were
also there david making it a rare outing
with his own 13 year old daughter harper
now adam has some practice when it comes
to nailing the bat mitzvah experience
you got adam levine
to the bat mitzvah that was unbelievable
it was the nicest thing and there it is
he came and sang and look look at that's
my daughter and that's that oh wow yeah
yeah that's big yeah
yeah back in 2019 he booked a different
atom adam levine to serenade sonny's
older sister sadie at her party how'd
you work that
i know he's such a good dude man i
texted him
i i i he he responded right away and
said yeah i'll come back he used to go
he grew up out here he used to go to bar
mitzvahs at this place we did it at and
he swung by
did three songs with his buddy from
maroon 5 and and uh it was like the
crowd was going every age was going
crazy kids adults my mother was horny it
was very nice now we don't know if sonny
secured a performer the same way for her
day but in our dreams adam took the
stage himself and channeled his inner
wedding singer and so it goes until the
day you die
this thing they call love he's gonna
make you cry i hate you